the jurogan experience hey holding up
did i move you out here at a bad time do
you think i mean we considered suing you
[Laughter]
i was sitting there going can i take
legal action against him like i called a
lawyer and apparently i cannot listen
i'll give you free meals yeah every time
we go out forever
we were i mean i was on a bread line two
days ago
my opener flies into town we're gonna
fly out for shows all the flight's
grounded we can't go anywhere
i mean we're waiting outside of a
supermarket for an hour and then we're
eating fish sticks in the dark of my
house with no power
and i'm like you know joe [ __ ] broken
man uh
this was a real [ __ ] leap of faith
but it's looking better today
it'll be fine it'll be fine it was a
once in they're calling it a once in a
hundred and twenty year storm
but i think what that means is like ever
recorded
like you go back to 1800 so what we're
talking about
or 1900 rather like when what was the
what kind of [ __ ] instruments were
they yeah what were they what were they
jotting down
almanac was the big thing back in those
days yeah how did that work
because that [ __ ] thing was
apparently kind of accurate it's kind of
witchcraft
this is crazy yeah they were crazy like
next year's
yeah winter slides yeah and harvests and
things like that yeah what did they do
how was
how did it work it was just wild driving
around texas and seeing
nothing but snow yeah and you it looked
like vermont
it looked like you were in the northeast
but it didn't it was like wild
to be in texas driving around and
nothing was open yeah
so like gas stations weren't open uh
fast food wasn't open
nothing was open no you know tell you
what was open to houston airport my boy
ted cruz was like yeah he was out
and by the way isn't it sad that like he
couldn't get away with it
it's like here's the thing about the
bush family say what you want about them
maybe wack to kennedy bygones but i mean
now our leaders can't even get caught
taking a commercial flight to cancun
like that's pretty sad but here's the
thing like
what can he do what is that what is the
reason for him staying
well i think it's just the optics of how
it looks yeah but of course
no he doesn't have any of can he make it
warm out i don't think he has any power
to do anything good
maybe he should be there with blankets
yeah well it's funny it's like the
people that hate him the most are the
ones that are like he should be there
it's like doing what well here's you
know here's the thing though
he was one of the vocal critics of mayor
adler
who's a democrat right who went to
cancun as well
right everybody goes to cancun i think
he was in cancun was he in cancun or was
he in uh
one of those is the thing at the house
yes but it was in cancun or was it
puerto vallarta
well it was one of those nice places in
mexico yeah and he wanted
and he's the mayor of austin yes he went
down there and he was saying now is not
the time to relax
yeah so he went in there i mean that's
the place to relax yeah i mean [ __ ]
sammy hagar's got a song about it i mean
it's crazy to watch it's also crazy that
he got
caught and then he came back well he
said i was always coming back i was
being a good father
yeah so you had to put a spin on it yeah
i was dropping my face i feel cause ted
cruz has the face of the guy
that always is caught like he looks like
the kid at school
who gets in on the prank too late and
then the teacher catches him like he
just
looks like he gets caught he's not he's
not one of those guys who gets away with
it
no matter what happens he doesn't get
away with it no he's
he's um did you ever see those videos
that they made
where it was i don't know who released
the full video
the videos that they made where he was
running for president and he
sat down with his mom and he was talking
about you know i go to church every day
and she's like yeah
every day right his mom threw him under
the bush like
yeah every day yeah yeah it's when i was
like [ __ ] you don't go to
[ __ ] church every day and it was like
they had a retake
scenes and it was oh the whole thing's a
nightmare but they showed it
how about somebody from the wife's group
text
leaked because they were inviting
neighbors going come to [ __ ] cabo or
wherever the hell come to cancun
and somebody leaked it to the new york
times going here's the group
text proving they were inviting us all i
wonder how many moms were in that group
text
too many yeah there there's these are
the videos oh this is great
but these things are always gross man
those like sit down with your mom
let's pretend the camera's not here
right
tell everyone how good i am i'm a good
person right now i'm a god-fearing
christian tell everyone what a good
person your son is
yeah he was very good though i have to
give him props
because there was this one situation
where what what was it it was a tech
thing
where he was [ __ ]
i don't remember god damn it we talked
about it on the podcast jamie do you
remember what it was
where he was uh calling them out
for god it's escaping me but i was
actually kind of
platforming people or privacy yes it was
like here it was a video of him from the
summer he's like who the hell are let's
see
who is he who is he critiquing though
who's he criticizing google
yes and it says ted cruz on google and
big tech
censorship yeah there was a who the hell
are you to decide who can speak
there was he was catching them in some
hypocrisy
and it was like it was very good the way
he was doing it and
well phrased like you gotta you gotta
give a little if you're gonna [ __ ] on
the guy
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on
spotify watch back catalog jre videos on
spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience